wired auto complete
answer event why can't we do this we had
that problem earlier
hey i'm tim heidecker and i'm john c
reilly
this is the wired auto complete
interview
who john c riley who is
john c wright starting off with an easy
question i am john c riley
this is lsd next question
who's sang john c reilly a
in walk hard who's saying you mean like
who's saying for me
how dare you ask me that question i sang
all of my sing own singing in that movie
and then every movie i've ever appeared
in
all the singing has always been me
although the birds had a great song
called john riley
and they sang that song that must have
been what they were
the old folk song called john riley i
recommend it
who is john c riley in guardians of the
galaxy
see i play uh corman day
who is part of the nova corps the kind
of intergalactic
police force there's no question marks
on any of these it's very hard to
to say these correctly who does johnson
does john c riley
look like very few people i look a lot
like
my brothers and sisters that's weird and
my father my late father
that was one of the things coming up as
an actor like
i was looking for an example like how
could i be an actor who is like me
and there was there was nobody like me
which i thought was a
was a problem but then someone explained
to me that's good because then you'll be
unique
but and the only thing i could ever
relate to as a kid was like
kind of mickey dolan's kind of elliot
ghouls like they had curly hair
like that was about it and oliver
however hardy
you think i look like oh you did when
you did all that when you did the movie
was that makeup it was like yeah
although the first my first meeting with
that director
i said what are you thinking about this
for i just lost a bunch of weight what
are you thinking about for this thing
he's like
well would you want to wear a suit and i
was like yeah
i'm not gaining 120 pounds now it's your
turn to be on the hot seat tim
uh-oh we've got garth to close my eyes
no that is tim heidecker it's really
glued him on tight reel
i think i can answer this question he's
very real i'm the real deal
but i do play fake characters named tim
hydeker so there's confusion there
good point and i i do need to think
about changing my
name i'm going to legally change my name
i've decided tim jones
is tim heidecker funny i personally
think tim is one of the first am i
supposed to answer oh yeah sorry
a lot of people don't think i'm funny
and that's fine
because there's a lot of people i don't
think are funny and it's relative i make
myself laugh
i laugh probably uh at myself more than
other people do but you seem to think
i'm funny and i have funny friends
you are funny but looks aren't
everything is tim heidecker
really run running for
district attorney my character is named
tim heidecker he ran for district
attorney and
lost a lot a couple years ago against
rosetti the rapper rosetta the rat
vincent rossetti is tim honaker married
sorry interesting i just had lunch with
tim and his wife
sorry ladies it's tim heidecker me
married to oh nice married to eric where
we
obviously jan skyler and wayne schuyler
are married the only married news
team in the tri-county area eric's
probably the man i've kissed the most
we are in a way married in a sort of
legal sense you know we
the your company the company exists it's
a legal
partnership get out of here oh here
comes
riley with round two man there's a full
box of questions
folks if you're bored now just this is a
lot more coming you're gonna hear
voiceover of letters that you've written
what dear mother the winter has come in
strong
i'm still doing the wired autocomplete
interview
what is the john c reilly
gif gif i mean there's a lot but
you know phil johnson try to tell me
that it's called gifs
okay they're not gifs okay they're gifts
phil just take this moment to tell phil
that probably the most famous gifts of
me
on the internet are ones that are
actually of someone else
dr steve bruhl i look a lot
like him so i guess you could say that's
a
gif of me i almost said jiff after
lecturing phil about how his gif
well i use that all the time to
communicate
those gifts gifs ah okay what is john
c reilly like in real life
that should be a secret i don't know if
you need to get into that that should be
missing
it's such a general question i'm all
right you know i'm
just a human being i have my interests
not perfect try to be healthy try to
have a lot of empathy i'm not putting on
some character right now this is what
i'm like
what is john c riley's eye color do you
know
ah i should have looked this is an easy
one i should get this
i was just in the bathroom in the mirror
um
my eyes are blue come on what is john c
reilly
band well my first band was called
shark fighter me and my brother had a
band called
shark fighter and then i had a band
called frozen spit
in my 20s and then i had a band called
stereo blues which is a blues band where
i played the harmonica and now my
current band is called john riley and
friends very easy to remember i also
call myself john riley and friends in
the band because
it's the one place i don't have to put
the c dang c
i'm required by sag to make my name john
c
reilly because there used to be another
john riley in the union i always thought
it was chauncey riley your name was
chauncy that's my secret pseudonym
okay tim oh yeah why was tim and there
cancelled were you canceled well we said
a lot of nasty things
you weren't canceled you walked away no
we
yeah we walked away to do a movie that
was very unsuccessful
why is tim and eric funny yeah well you
know
again relatively let's skip this
question i don't appreciate the grammar
i'm just full of controversy why are tim
and eric so
weird we love weirdness we love
weirding you out we love being weird and
random
[Laughter]
i'm working on a new character weird
because he's real my name is
my name is john pig
all right he's weird because the world
is weird and if you
react to it in an honest way you are
weird why is john the internet
why is john c reilly an actor uh i'm an
actor because
i love to tell a story it's because
people started to pay me to do it and it
became my life
i didn't really set out to be an actor
why is john c reilly on
tim and eric i'm not on tim and eric i'm
an executive producer on
check it out with dr steve bruhl you had
a lot of the finances and discussions
i do a lot of the scheduling and
budgeting
why why john c reilly voice actor why
john c reilly voice actor
why not because uh it's fun to be a
voice actor you can wear whatever you
want
no one puts makeup on your face or
anything weird like that you just go in
and
goof around and then if you make a
mistake you just do it again there's
never any pressure when you're doing
voiceover work it's just like yeah we
got time
but you're unique and distinctive on the
eyes for us but also on the ears you've
got a very
you got your own which i have discovered
during the pandemic times i wear
full masks sunglasses hat whatever
people are like love your work
you hear me say one thing like you know
i'll have a order of fries and it's like
holy [ __ ]
i love your work like wow can tim
heidecker cook
yeah i can cook it's easy can tim
heidecker sing
no mama me me me ma mama of course
yeah tim actually released a great
record called
fur fear of death fear of death can tim
heidecker act well tune in to moon base
eight
on november 8th and you'll see him act
his ass off with me and
fred armisen can tim heidecker stand up
let's see
come on you can do better than that yeah
he can stand up all right
in fact he has a stand-up special coming
out that's right what's that called
uh an evening with tim hydex an evening
of ten hot i could look for that
how how to contact john c riley
let me just use this opportunity to tell
everyone out there i am
not on social media in any way so if you
see someone says
john c reilly official or verified or
whatever the hell
it ain't me folks it ain't me it ain't
me man i don't have enough time to do
the
things i like to do in my life let alone
things like social media
how tall is john c reilly what would
possibly be in
feet six two but i used to say six one
and a half so it sounded like i wasn't
too tall right on my resume
how old was john c riley
in gilbert grape oh and gilbert and
gilbert grapes
how what was my age let's see that movie
was made in 1992
i believe and i was born in 65
75 85 oh this is where i lose my math i
was twenty
twenty eight eight how did john c right
this is good
i don't think i know the answer this how
did john c reilly and will ferrell meet
we met through molly shannon i was
friends with molly i'd done a movie with
her called never been kissed
and i was in new york and i think i had
brunch with molly and she's like you
should meet my friend you
you guys would really get along you
would love him
will came and met us on the west side
highway in manhattan
where we were walking to molly's
apartment and i looked at will and i was
like
oh my god she's right i totally like
this guy
like soul connection really like is he
on snl yeah
he's on snl with her at the time but i
didn't just didn't really know it was
early days
i almost did feel related to him in some
weird way
tim what is tim heidecker it's height
nine what is tinnitic or zodiac nine
what
what is tim heineker's versus what is
tim heidecker versus california
what does that mean oh well that was the
trial
probably when uh that was probably the
official name it was the reference to
another earlier
on cinema tim portrayed himself
what are tim heidecker kitchen tips this
is one of my favorite shows that tim's
ever done
tim's kitchen tips it's a very
sauce-heavy kitchen
cooking show it was you know on facebook
a few years ago there was all those
videos where it was just those the
ukulele playing and it was
everyone just mixing things and making
everything look so easy
and all you do then there's this and
there's this and it's like this
compounded on top of each other
and i just said well why don't we do
that just making russian dressing which
is just two ingredients but then
it's about five minutes of stirring it
really is amazing
check out tim's kitchen tips what is tim
heidecker's
offer us hours nah 10 a.m on thursdays
uh on the youtube channel of tim
heidecker's youtube channel and it's
it's sort of my larry king live yeah
it's like tim you decided to just like
reach out to the fans directly mm-hmm
and really just give you you started
calling in early on and you would call
in
because you were just sitting at home
having breakfast yeah and you'd call in
and go on and on about your acai bowls
that you were eating
yeah and the joke was i would go okay
thank you
next caller yeah i wanted to support you
and now look it's become this huge thing
it's the number one podcast
in the world my final thoughts on what
the internet wants to know about me is
like
maybe the internet should be a little
more creative like these these are
things that are very easily answered for
the most part
i would be googling more things like you
know how can i find meaning
uh how do i how can i help my community
how can i learn to be more empathetic
yeah and and and more
don't worry about people like us we're
we could we're not very interested we're
doing fine
you know one thing i would like to ask
the internet's help with whatever
questions you ask about me
just google my name as many times as you
can because i'm in a
hot competition with john c calhoun
and john c mcginley auto complete it's
john c
and then yeah calhoun no no no no
you want john c reilly so everyone just
pump my name in there as many times as
you can
flush calhoun calhoun was not a great
president he's not a president
yeah he was there's no way he was the
president wish we had the answer to
reveal
uh i'm sorry i can name all the
presidents and he's not one can he yeah
i'm gonna guess he was a senator john c
and look my name comes off first john c
calhoun
is former vice president
of the united states he was a heartbeat
away from the president am i
right or wrong he was a heartbeat away
he wasn't a senator
all right so folks help me out get this
calhoun bum off my
search engine